you have staked out so many
areas you've done so much great work but
you've also been once you're in a Star
Wars film
you've got you're part of that whole
lore do you have Star Wars fans coming
up to you all the time not all the time
there's
I mean it is a cult it is yeah there's
so many movies and spin-offs my other
thing no you're diluting the whole thing
I think that's my personal thing and um
but yeah occasionally
you know
kids after a Star Wars autograph and I
don't want to give autographs we're at
an airport oh it's not the kid it's the
grandfather there he is or the dad you
know horn Rim glasses and a beard yeah
yeah and they're like they become 11
year olds you know yeah did you uh did
you enjoy uh because I know that you and
you McGregor got to use the uh the
lightsabers did you have fun with those
it did uh the first time we actually had
to use pull the lightsaber and there's
only a handle right it's a handle and
they add the effect later yeah and maybe
a little bit of uh aluminum tube with
green tape mines was green because I'm
wearing Irish jelly
onions was right out of them yeah so the
first time we got to pull them to start
a little fight you know we both
automatically went and actually
you
you know
wait you were doing that with your mouth
[Music]
[Laughter]
uh let's cut there boys we can add that
in later
of course we knew that
that's hilarious I wish they had left
that in wouldn't that be so great
spitting at each other
God that would be so so funny looking
that would be fantastic I had this uh
lovely makeup and hair lady
and uh Scottish and uh
I was supposed to be doing the scene
with this
little flying sort of monster that was
this kid that would eventually be Darth
Vader he's nine years of age sure
um it was a big long scene with those
flying things what do you want that's
all that sort of stuff
and uh I didn't know what this thing was
going to look like so I'm you know I'm
acting to a guy with a steak and a
orange or a green tennis ball stuck in
the top that's going to be eventually
this flying little monster right
and
so I'm in the makeup so I got my wagon
my beard and all that stuff
and she says oh Liam makeup Lady says um
I did see uh you know a mock-up of the
Wii
the monster
you could be a monkey smoking the pipe
no one's going to be looking at you
isn't that nice to hear just before you
go before you do it and I had a lot of
lines to say on this thing you know to
this tennis ball you know
and right enough you see the scene it's
like oh wow that's amazing what are you
doing here today
I'll show you
you idiots you don't need to make the
sound with your mouth
um it's uh you know what's incredible to
me that you've you know had a very
distinguished career you've done a lot
of great work you're a terrific actor
and then this is the way it goes
eventually in this business you are
acting to
a green tennis ball yeah and because
that's more and more that's what the
work is and it's just uh I don't know
about you but there's so many times
particularly in in my profession my
career
my weird corner of it where I find
myself doing these things over the years
over the many years and I think
I step outside my body and go what the
hell are you doing you're this is you're
you're a complete fool you're at what is
it you're a total ass but I think you
we're in Show Business ultimately so
um even something as you know important
and popular as a Star Wars film you're
there and there's a tennis ball and
there must be some part of you that
steps outside I did theater I know I
know yeah yeah there's that but what
you've done come on to me that would be
a nightmare for me getting up as Conan
O'Brien or Liam Neeson in front of an
audience
and haven't they entertain them
that's a nightmare the thought of I'm
not a comedian right like that I mean
you are you've done that stuff I was
like how did they did that
uh well the trick is sometimes it's not
good that's what I've always said
the trick is you go out and you try but
uh
um I don't know I don't I know that I
love it I love being in front of people
and uh I really enjoy it but I get very
intense before I go out and do it and I
was telling you just before I went on
just last night I did something with
Paul McCartney
about 800 people I think in the crowd
and
um had the time of my life out there on
stage but beforehand waiting backstage
standing next to that guy and I had to
go out first and get the crowd going and
then bring him out right
it's things get very focused in my brain
and I still after all these years I I
get kind of intense because I think you
have to get that way before you go out
if you just breeze on out there it's not
going to be any good yeah I remember
just upper boom what we're talking about
I remember doing a play a Brian Friel
play new play then it was called
aristocrats
in the Belfast theater Festival I'm
talking 1978 or something
and I had taken over the part from
wonderful Irish identical Stephen Ray oh
yeah and I had learned the part in two
weeks and I was a main a main part you
know
we played in Dublin for two weeks then
we had a week off
while the company moved up to Belfast
first part of this festival and on the
opening night of the player Aristocrats
which I'd already played for two weeks
Brian's in the audience the directors on
the airlines various Northern Ireland
dignitaries and I have a kind of drunken
Spiel to say in the second act
and I dried
for your audience I forgot my words
um you could have heard a pin drop and I
remember seeing at the end of the the
passageway
the exit sign
and I thought if I jump off the stage
and I can be out of this horrible
feeling
uh in
maybe six seconds and all this is over
uh I didn't but it felt like an hour had
passed and I was still there looking at
this exit sign and the audience
look at me I eventually I was supposed
to be drunk the characters so I kind of
staggered off stage and the script girls
she wasn't following it at all anyway
when I got off stage I remembered the
lane and I staggered back on again
resumed the purple so it came back to
you it came back to me but I'll never
forget that moment of
absolute
terrifying fear I kept thinking I
sometimes get obsessed with the World
War One the Battle of this song oh yeah
because I had a neighbor in my street
who served in the psalm twice
uh and the things he must have seen I
remember thinking those soldiers before
they got over the entrances must have
been feeling some similar to that it was
almost like a near-death experience for
me I'll never forget
it's funny do you have you ever figured
out what happened in that moment why you
know because you knew it you obviously
knew it was there something in that
moment was there a reason was it because
everyone was in the audience because I
find sometimes I don't like to know yeah
if someone
importance in the crowd sure I don't
want to know yeah yeah I'd rather not
know because then that gets in my head
and I used to find it difficult
even when family would come and they
would say like oh you're my Dad's here
and he's gonna sit in the crowd that
would make it more difficult for me
which shouldn't make a difference at all
now I know but it would make it more
difficult even though it's a TV show
it's going out to millions of homes
that's who's really seeing it this
audience you know but but I I couldn't
get past that yeah I think it is it's
part partly knowing that
various people out there that are you
respect you know and I just dropped
conversation I think I felt too
confident I had taken over the part in
two weeks which was fast learned for me
very fast yeah and uh I think it just
caught up with me that's what it was I
think it's refreshing I love it when
people especially people of your caliber
say I'm scared and I still get scared
you know I I and I find that to be it's
one of the things I like most about
doing the podcast and having these
conversations is I love
I think it's good for people to hear
that that
Liam Neeson still has moments and I you
know we all do we all do we have these
moments where we think I don't know that
I can do this oh yeah I still give them
not that fear but
if I'm shooting a film and you know or
there's a break they're doing a lighting
setup or something right I'll look at
the lines or whatever I'm thinking
why do I do this yeah
I always say to myself you know I think
it was Robert mating myself in some
interview years ago
so as you walk in the room you point
your feet speak the truth or walk in the
room hit the marks say the lines what's
the problem yeah oh my God you know I
something assembles thought well can it
get me back again it worked for Robert
Mitchum yeah I'll say that and Jimmy
Cagney Cagney used to say that too
no stress no strain walking the room
plant your feet speak the truth
that was this thing yeah well he was in
Jimmy Cagney he was uh I grew up I mean
it's odd but I think just because you
know I grew up I came of age in the
1970s so you'd think I'd be watching all
this sophisticated stuff but
no I ran I watched channel 38 or Channel
56 because they showed reruns of and
what did they show they showed old
movies so I grew up on Jimmy Cagney and
I thought that was Show Business Jimmy
Cagney and Yankee Doodle Dandy angels
with dirty faces you know uh Public
Enemy I just thought that's what those
were the movies I watched and
um me too yeah and I thought that's what
it is and of course I wasn't watching
Mean Streets I wasn't watching I didn't
have access to those they weren't
showing those uh early Scorsese films
that's what I should have been watching
but you know that's what I that was my
education was the 1930s and 40s Warner
Brothers yeah me too and then we we go
to TV
God is in my teens I think when we go to
TV black and white you know but I always
remember every Sunday there was always a
movie on
two o'clock in the afternoon and uh it
always seemed to be someone in a MAG
with the trilby hat pouring with rain
yeah film Noir Raymond Chandler yeah
Alan Ladd or Mitchum or something like
that you know so I feel I kind of grew
up with those guys